hey guys seven I just finished the
marathon session I recorded 14 videos
that are going to go up in the youtube
channel i had a great session this
morning with with my media coach and
overall awesome person Jenny and and I'm
I'm burning out now my head is pounding
the videos I'm really proud of the I
really feel like I laughed a lot of
myself into each video i really put it
out there and it took a lot of me this
time to create these videos for you and
i hope you like in them i hope you're
enjoying the videos i know we have a you
know fanbase that's hardcore and loves
them and watches each one and some
people are commenting and i really love
seeing those come in and I just
encourage you to put all of yourself
today into your business do something
that tomorrow you're gonna look back on
and say you know what I'm proud of what
I did yesterday I'm really proud of what
happened and I feel like I left it all
out there and and I couldn't give any
more and I hope you don't end up with
the headache that I have right now um
but i know i'm gonna look back when
these videos go up i'm gonna be really
proud of the content that I made and the
people whose questions I I answered and
so I'm wishing that for you today do
something today that you're gonna really
feel proud of that you're not you know
you're not checking your Facebook status
you're not doing something to just kill
the time you're you're doing something
you you're going to do something today
that matters that mean something that's
going to help somebody and just put
everything you've got into it you know
do it just for today do it and see how
that makes you feel and see if that
gives you the momentum you need to keep
growing and keep building your business
I hope you'll do it today and make sure
you have some tylenol handy just in case
thanks guys see you soon